I want to say one thing to the American
people I want you to listen to me I'm
going to say this again I did not have
sexual relations with that woman miss
Lewinsky indeed I did have a
relationship with Miss Lewinsky that was
not appropriate in fact it was wrong it
constituted a critical lapse in judgment
and a personal failure on my part for
which I am solely and completely
responsible that was President Bill
Clinton's infamous lie about his
relationship with Monica Lewinsky for
years we have been shining a light on
the allegations of sexual misconduct by
President Clinton and again liberals
have given him a pass for nearly 30
years
the women that have been involved
smeared slandered besmirched thrown down
the stairs bimbo eruptions
we have left-wing comedian Chelsea
Handler actually tweeted an apology last
night - Juanita Broderick for not
knowing her story handlers tweet read in
part quote you're right I apologize to
you for not knowing your story Democrats
along with Republicans and the rest of
the world's political parties all need
to do a better and respect at first-hand
accounts of victims I believe you
joining us with reaction to my opening
monologue of more foxnews contributors
Tommy Lehren Jessica thar love you know
there's a guy called senator Grove I
mean he's grabbing a sleeping woman's
breast this isn't an allegation it's not
a he-said she-said we have the evidence
absolutely we do have the evidence I
refutable as you said in your opening
monologue as well Democrats have been
swift to condemn it I actually haven't
seen anyone defended including senator
Franken himself and even called for an
investigation into his own actions I
think he acted pretty responsibly
considering the irresponsible actions
that set this all off and most
importantly we need to consider the fact
that we are officially in a territory of
no partisan affiliation with this we've
got gross guys on both sides of the
aisle and we shouldn't be making any
arguments on the basis of who we'd like
to see in office it's interesting as I
in the case of the Roy Moore situation I
said the same thing if true it's
despicable it's true it's disgusting I
did it a hard interview with him
a lot of people you know said praise me
for the interview and I said you've got
to answer these questions the end of the
day is going to be the people of
Minnesota and the people of Alabama I
think where the real difference is here
where you look at what Al Franken and
how he's responding you look at a Roy
Moore you even look at what happened
when Donald Trump was accused of sexual
assault there has been a Donald Trump I
interviewed most of those women the New
York Times put in there they all said it
was false
some of us and I take it back no they
came on this program go back and look at
that article I brought many of them on
this show and they all said they were
taken out of context purposely by the
New York Times okay well either I know
that summers address is still moving
forward this either way there is a
proper way to deal with these
allegations what do you think that if
that was Donald Trump that picture well
he would still be President people heard
the Access Hollywood tape and you said
in your opening monologue what would the
media be doing if this was in the media
totally crazy
when it was Donald Trump at native and
you would evaluate and liberals in this
country protect the Clintons for 30
years I mean I haven't been alive and
commentator long it would appear that
way yes and there are a lot of it more
than they did no but this is also being
led by a younger generation I think that
point is important there he is and Matt
Iglesias and I think that that's
important they're people who did not
grow up with the Clintons they were not
paying attention but we do know this we
know they got a pass even in 2016 no no
we got a pass because she took money
from countries that abuse women kill
gays and lesbians persecuted Christians
and Jews and nobody wanted to hear when
that second debate happened and and
Juanita and Paula and Kathleen with air
Tommy well and this goes beyond Bill
Clinton it goes to Hillary as well and I
know that the liberals hate it when we
still talk about Hillary but it's
important if we go all the way back to
Bill and then we follow it through
Hillary she just ran for president on
the whole woman card the whole female
empowerment
Hillary is just as responsible as Bill
was as you mentioned the bimbo Tommy
squad Tommy if Bill Clinton raved
Juanita Broderick I don't know how you
can say that Hillary Clinton is just as
responsible as Bill
come I think about what you're saying
here I understand you want to see and
enable yes wouldn't that make her an
enabler if you were having you symbol
eruption in the works of blackmail and
discredit your users are you having
people responsible there is
responsibility and then there is raping
someone they are completely different
you are conflating two very separate
things that I don't think that I just
got some I just got some breaking news
senator Kristin Gillibrand of New York
is now saying Bill Clinton should have
resigned over the Lewinsky affair and
here's the thing that point that I made
last night I think you know more about
the Clintons you know Doug shown very
well I don't but the reality is you have
Kathleen Willey I took the time and I
went and interviewed them I interviewed
the second interview that Juanita gave
first to Lisa Myers than me and nobody
wanted to pay attention in the media in
this campaign it was brought up Hillary
just saw those old news is it really
when you say you're the the women's
champion in the world you take money
from countries that abused women she's
never said that she said women have a
right to be believed but she never
commented on the women that accused her
husband well I think is that is that
hypocritical on our part yes it is and
she suffered for it I mean if you look
at the female turnout for her if you
look at even what happened in the
Democratic primaries where Bernie
Sanders won 18 to 29 year olds and I
believe in 80% of the contact contest by
a 6 to 1 ratio you know that she was
hurt by her brand of feminism and that a
lot of things that she was saying did
not ring true to people again I'm going
back to what Tommy just said oh it's
really a separate issue to have been the
wife of someone who's accused of Ravens
who haven't actually raped someone I
think that Clintons were certainly
protected by liberal an interview with
Juanita Broderick I did actually I did
on the network last year it's certainly
a compelling story I've read a lot of
accounts of this I read what can start
believing willie i if you believe that
everyone for hours was thrown down the
stairs and 60 minutes in 92 and it
turned out bill clinton under oath had
to admit he had an affair with jennifer
flowers yes I mean he obviously had an
affair with these women I I understand
how serious these accusations are if we
are going to be the party of women's
before champion properly way
Paul Jones and one we're not that was
not consensual all three of them all
right Tommy let's bring you well of
course it wasn't consensual and now look
at this stuff when we go back and we
look at it you have to set a precedent
the precedent was Bill and everyone
wanted to look the other way when it was
Bill and then all of a sudden when the
Republicans now the lights being shone
on them of course we're still talking
about Donald Trump we're talking about
an Access Hollywood tape meanwhile we
have disgusting pictures right in front
of us why we're still going back to
Donald Trump I don't understand when we
should be talking about the precedent
center which was Bill Clinton which was
Hillary Clinton I'm still going to stick
to that Hillary was a part of this I put
it up for Bill the mainstream you look I
know for them Tony if you're going by a
sign line I believe Roy Moore was
allegedly assaulting fourteen-year-old
before Bill Clinton whispering I wanted
to tell you just what Tommy I'll give
you a chance to answer God we didn't
know about why more until two weeks ago
it might have happened long long ago but
how long have we known about Bill how
long have we known this and how long is
the mainstream media shielded him
shielded Hillary still said I'm with her
female empowerment first female
president I'm sorry did one thought as
my first female president someone that
had a bimbo eruption squad and worked to
discredit bills accusers I'm not with
her but still used to it by her you were
with her where were you where were the
feminists Jessica where were you they
were sitting right here in this chair
they were sitting all over the country
supporting a woman who is advocating an
agenda that would have made women's
lives in this country better by raising
the minimum wage by getting quality
affordable health care I totally take
she took money from countries where
women are told how the State Department
excuse me she took millions of dollars
from countries for her foundation that
abused women told women are told how to
dress they can't travel without a male
permission they can't vote in some of
these countries marital rape is legal in
some of these countries domestic abuse
is legal in some of these countries she
took millions from those countries
Jessica I think I know you wouldn't take
a dime from people that have those
beliefs would you well I don't work in
that kind of you if you had the chance
when she was in the State Department no
I'm talking about the Clinton know
they should husband's handy for the
clinic would you say wrong would you
taste would you take money from
countries that abuse women kill gays and
lesbians for who they are and persecute
Christians and Jews would you know there
are better countries to take money from
but Donald Trump has businesses already
in those countries as well as Darwin
Kushner
it's amazing how we're always back to
Donald Trump we really cannot stay on
the Clintons we can't talk about Hillary
because it always goes back to Trump
well he hasn't moved ask me about Tommy
Hillary Clinton old try that for the
segment you both a really tough question
we have about 20 seconds each is tough
though Tommy I'll start with you what do
you do in these cases when it's he said
she said and then it becomes he said
versus she said she said she said how do
people is I think it's important to
people know truth how do you get to the
truth I don't know how you get to the
truth but I'm hoping if there's a silver
lining in all this is that the young
women on either side of the political
divide will find the courage to speak up
and not wait 20 years I think that
moving forward that's going to be the
best solution so if you have an issue of
a problem someone touched you you didn't
want to be touched say something as it's
happening because we're in a climate
right now where you have the opportunity
to stand up and so I would hope that
women across the board would be able and
be empowered enough to do this 122nd I
agree with that and women in this
country are having a moment and I think
it's incredibly important suddenly
people are interested in hearing their
stories and I would also add that there
are a lot of industries that are not
being paid attention to we happen to
work in media and media and politics is
shiny and bright and people will pay
attention to them however the music
industry absolutely there are countless
people working in fast food restaurants
we're getting harassed every day who are
you know working in homes and not being
treated properly so speak up and use
whatever platform you can thank you both
for being with us appreciate Tommy